quiero hablar sobre una de las ideas más
raras en el procesamiento de señales y
es la idea de frecuencia negativa ya que
puede que no tenga ningún sentido qué
significa tener una frecuencia negativa
podríamos tener una onda seno que vaya
arriba y abajo con una tasa de menos 10
ciclos por segundo qué es eso o
podríamos tener una estación de radio
que transmita a menos 680 kilos hertz
esto no suena que tenga sentido alguno
pero veremos que la frecuencia negativa
es comprensible y vamos a hablar sobre
eso aquí recuerden que podemos describir
un coche no así el coseno de omega por t
es igual a un medio que multiplica
a la j omega t positivo
más el elevado a la menos j omega por t
y cada uno de estos componentes estos
exponentes complejos de aquí podemos
dibujarlos como un número complejo que
rota o que gira para este primero si
queremos podríamos graficar lo así un
número complejo aquí en el espacio
imaginen lo como un vector que rota y
esto es que a la j omega t positivo y
este otro término de aquí va a verse
bastante similar será un vector en el
espacio y este es el número es la menos
j omega t y éste va a estar rotando en
la dirección negativa es decir va a
estar rotando así así que la idea de una
frecuencia negativa cuando hablamos de
vectores que rotan tiene sentido si
rotamos en la dirección positiva así
podremos decir que es una frecuencia
positiva y si rota de la dirección
negativa diremos que es una frecuencia
negativa por lo que omega t nos va a dar
la rapidez
y este signo de acá y este signo de aquí
nos van a dar la dirección aquí la
frecuencia es más omega t y aquí abajo
la frecuencia es menos omega t así que
cuando usamos vectores que rotan la
frecuencia negativa no tiene ningún
problema es una idea bastante simple
pero ahora pasemos a donde no es una
idea sencilla y esto es cuando hacemos
lo que ya habíamos hecho con
anterioridad cuando proyectamos estos
vectores en una onda coseno y
distribuimos el eje del tiempo
linealmente así hacia abajo para el
coseno recuerden lo que hicimos
dibujamos un vector en este lado vamos a
dibujar omega t positivo así que gráfica
moshe a la j omega t positivo este es el
eje real y este es el eje imaginario y
aquí tendremos el eje del voltaje y por
acá estará el eje del tiempo comenzamos
con el tiempo igual a cero proyectamos
esto hacia abajo
este valor de aquí conforme avanza el
tiempo aquí tendremos nuestro vector y
se va a proyectar en la onda coseno aquí
sin nuestro vector llega hasta el otro
lado se va a proyectar en este punto de
la curva coseno y continuamos ahora
llegamos aquí abajo y éste se va a
proyectar aquí y cuando llegamos aquí se
va a proyectar
en este punto de acá y cuando regresamos
a cero la proyección estará acá
y con una rotación 'hemos graficado un
ciclo del coseno esto es bastante claro
omega t está aquí arriba y también así
está omega t aquí abajo vamos a hacer lo
mismo pero en esta ocasión vamos a usar
la frecuencia negativa vamos a graficar
el ala menos j omega t nuevamente este
es el eje real este es el eje imaginario
aquí está el eje del voltaje y aquí el
eje del tiempo vamos a comenzar
iniciamos en el punto del tiempo igual a
0 lo proyectamos hacia abajo y llegamos
a este punto en la curva y es el mismo
que teníamos en el otro dibujo el mismo
valor desde aquí ahora rotamos esto
hacia abajo un poco esta es la nueva
posición del vector y esta proyección
llega a este punto si nuestro vector
ahora está acá ya que roto un poco más
su protección va a estar aquí y cuando
llega a este otro lado su proyección
acá y pueden ver lo que está ocurriendo
básicamente está ocurriendo lo mismo que
en el dibujo de la izquierda que es que
estos puntos están generando una onda
coseno tal como lo esperamos y cuando
este vector regresa hasta el punto
inicial a cero hemos hecho un ciclo y
ahora se proyectará en este punto de acá
lo que hicimos aquí fue tomar dos
vectores y rotar los en direcciones
diferentes
este claramente tenía una frecuencia
positiva por que rotaba en sentido
antihorario este tiene una frecuencia
negativa porque rota en sentido horario
y ambos generaron la misma onda coseno
así que en el mundo de los vectores en
donde estamos girando vectores es muy
natural hablar de frecuencias positivas
y negativas pero cuando transformamos
esto en gráficas digamos de la vida real
dvd te noten que la idea de frecuencias
negativas
se evapora ya no existe fue eliminado
por este proceso de proyección así que
cuando hablemos de la idea de frecuencia
negativa y les parezca que no tenga
sentido en esta vista del dominio del
tiempo de las señales recuerden que
cuando regresamos aquí al dominio de los
vectores y vemos los vectores que giran
la frecuencia negativa nos indicará
hacia dónde está rotando el vector
esto significará hacia dónde está
rotando el vector